yes my hair has been restored
oh yes my hair has been restored to a
perfect pristine red ignore the fact
that my blood Oh
spoilers ignore the fact that my scalp
is still dyed blood red
I had to dip my entire head into the
blood of my enemies to get a proper
thorough dye that's the only way I know
how to do it so let's get back to a game
where we are about to die over and over
repeatedly and you guys don't have to
worry about making me mad VIN Lulu I was
literally about to say you guys don't
have to worry about me making any
mistakes but I'm an expert linguist
everyone says to themselves in hushed
whispers late into the night that mark
is the greatest linguist to ever Lingle
it's a hope that's what they say about
me anytime I try to talk good about
myself and don't know work too good but
I ain't gonna deny that I'll press on
I'm the greatest that ever was in
something I don't know what yet I'm
still trying to find but I'm the
greatest maybe this game but probably
not so let's find out okay so I was
informed by you lovely people in the
comments in the last game and you
probably told me about this before
but the code to get the ventilation back
up and running is in that like police
like um ooh where am I now
oh I remember what's going on I [ __ ]
it I have [ __ ] it I don't know I
remember that but if I recall wasn't
okay so what I'm gonna do is it's in
that police like preparation room that's
where the code is and I believe it's
randomly generated so it wouldn't be
exactly the same that you guys have seen
before and I'm hoping that they are
docile right now and they're gonna be
docile
that's okay it ain't nothing and then a
whole lot of dick I'm too brave and you
strong to be thwarted by the Suches as
you okay so they said in like the bottom
corner of something there's like a code
handsome man tell me the code it's like
a code
some oh wait there it is to five one six
okay that's the code right ooh we got a
cold I don't know if it's gonna do
anything two five one six let's not
forget that one but I need to rush over
to the ventilation thing and then I need
to rush over and get a card but uh
before I die we're gonna put in this
code goo five one six enter yes oh
please tell me that's gonna fix it all
and I'm gonna be able to see okay I'm
assuming that did good right did that do
proper and did that do good I think my
vision is restoring to normal I mean I
still can't see anything in front of me
but goddamn it that fixed the stupid
things I'm gonna be so happy
oh okay where are they I need to go get
the card from their back their neck
their back oh not your that [ __ ] damn
[ __ ] cat that didn't work I didn't I
didn't nail that one that joke didn't
land didn't stick but a debit to be able
to OBD but I boo ever ah that ain't good
that ain't good I lost my chance to get
a card I might as well die I might as
well die okay so I need to be my niblets
move they've been doubled 1 6 7 7 on the
man I'm the man with the code BAM bada
bing bada boom I got it ok so now I need
to go fine to see who's got the card but
who does have the card question mark boo
not you again so it must be Wolfie in
the middle of this room here which is
probably gonna go bad for me because
he's probably gonna wake up probably
probably probably lobbed it probably's
where did it go why is he not here why
is he not here I don't like
oh that's not good I hear I thumpy thump
but I don't see a thumpy thump worthy
thump egde the ventilation should be
coming back so what I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna I'm gonna charge my do daddy
get under here tower like a [ __ ] a
little baby [ __ ] boy that's what I am
call me that from now on and then I'm
gonna do a little exercises pump up
muscles and then get out there and punch
him in the gonads because that's all I
know how to do extreme gonad punches if
they got balls prepare to get destroyed
if they got ovaries well that's a bit
that's better protected but I'm still
gonna go for them either one I'm all
fists imper oh yeah I forgot I needed to
get a card from the back of them oh I
have [ __ ] myself hello hello hi hello
haha nope six three oh there he is he's
here now
do you have it on the back your neck you
do for six three three I got this like
it's the key card Hey look I get your
key card for some kinda door well they
better go hon yet 463 okay here we go
I'm the man I'm the man I'm the man I'm
the man for sex free free okay now that
we got that that's been inputted
correctly and that's gonna drop the
temperature down and then I'm gonna be
able to see better and also I remember
there being some dialog about here so
maybe this was necessary going through
here and just damn yeah see yeah the car
just went away so that means it was
supposed to be used there if it went
away afterwards so now I imagine it's
just a survival game right just gonna
try to stay alive yeah okay yeah this
isn't where I wanted to go now what the
hell am I supposed to do because I got
the key card from the back of one of
them I tried it on the front door it
went out of my inventory so I gotta
imagine that something else is gonna
trigger here
but I'm not entirely sure Ward's a 47
stuck under this desk no end in sight
animatronics still haven't run out of
batteries it seems a feet off my fear
and I've got a lot of that what I don't
have a lot of is food shelter and a
place to go to the bathroom I have
completely filled the underneath of this
desk with my feces it's very disgusting
please help me where do they keep going
oh hey whoa
they why'd they shut down again is that
just what they're doing what is there
like another key card that I need to
find am I supposed to find the right key
card is oh my god is that the idea here
is that the idea okay
oh hi whoa how long were you there
I was listening that heartbeat for a
long time
oh I don't get this I don't get this
what the [ __ ] do I do now am I am i
boned mmm I've owned my boner owned meye
meye bow is this me dead are you shut
down or are you for realsies
cuz that's a good question I'm not sure
what I should do hey oh hey oh hey oh
okay
so bro can you you're not active okay so
I'm gonna take this I'm gonna go away oh
dammit [ __ ] [ __ ] so here's my
strategy this is this what I'm gonna do
and you guys are gonna see me do it
because I got a lot of time and I'm
gonna make sure that this gets done
right I have a feeling they're gonna go
through routine shutdown patterns so
what happens is the first key cards
gonna be wrong then I'm gonna find
another key card on the back of them for
some reason then I'm gonna find another
and I need to keep going and trying
until it works correctly
I guess whoa Nelly
hello hi friend are you doing nice bulge
nice Fupa that's a quality food you got
the card
he's got the card he's got the card
that's good
ah he shut down yes okay I was right
like it's the key card for some door huh
haven't I been through this before okay
so try this one I bet it's not gonna be
the one oh oh yes yes
maybe oh don't know yay I just kind of
stuck my face into the corner by the
door that's not exactly escaping but
I'll take it there we go we did it yeah
everybody celebrate dancing the streets
I finally did it and I only needed
marginal amounts of help I was actually
very close in the last episode but I
didn't even know that but there we go
that is KC animatronics this game took
me way too long to beat I know that I am
sorry about that that is my fault my
fault alone I let this video get away
from me and transitioning into this new
recording space and all that jazz and
all the stuff that happened with packs
and traveling this one kinda just fell
through the cracks and I apologize for
that I meant to get this done in like a
week it took like a month but either way
it is done I hope you guys enjoyed it it
was an interesting challenge I feel like
there could have been a lot more
substance to it because at the end of
the day you think about it you're just
wandering around the very same small
level and a lot of it gets a little
repetitive after a while and the threat
of the enemy is always constant in the
game which is you know I think what you
got to be careful with constant threat
not escalating threat I mean more
animatronics that are functionally the
same isn't always escalating the threat
it's just making the same threat
multiplied which can still get boring so
I feel like there could have been new
and interesting ways that this could
have come at you but it was still a good
job so I can't say it's too terrible
because it was actually a well made game
well put-together voice acting was a
little dull but I will
that go so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]
holy [ __ ] everything about that
stairwell screams I'm gonna die